guys I think it's time to reset the
simulation the founder of my pillow a
guy named Mike Lindell a right-wing
lunatic a total trump brown-nosing
sycophant
he was invited to speak yesterday at the
White House coronavirus press briefing
and he praised Trump as a gift from God
to the United States if you've not heard
of my pillow maybe you don't watch Fox
News at 2:00 a.m. my pillow is a foam
pillow sold in infomercials and often on
Fox News itself and my pillow is going
to retool there with some other
factories to manufacture masks for
healthcare workers which is great that's
fantastic
Mike Lyndell was invited to speak during
yesterday's press briefing and he went
completely off the rails reading a
statement off of a crinkled piece of
paper that Trump is literally a gift
from God given to the United States in
November of 2016 check this out
I wrote something off the cuff if I can
read this God gave us grace on November
8 2016 to change the course we were on
God had been taken out of our schools
and lives a nation had turned his back
on God and I encourage you use this time
at home to get back to home to get back
in the word read our Bibles and spend
time with our families our president
gave us so much hope we're just a few
short months ago we had the best economy
the lowest unemployment and wages going
up it was amazing with our great
president vice president and this
administration and all the great people
in this country praying daily we will
get through this and get back to a place
that's stronger and safer than ever
thank you please come on
I did not know he was gonna do that but
he's a friend of mine and I do
appreciate it why did God give us Trump
in November of 2016 and give us the
stock market and wages and all the stuff
Mike's referring to but then give us
coronavirus with nearly a million
confirmed worldwide cases nearly 40,000
deaths maybe more than 40,000 by the
time this clip gets published why
wouldn't God just not give us
coronavirus to begin with and we'd all
be far better off oh no David how dare
you God works in mysterious ways he gave
us Trump and coronavirus and he gave us
Trump to deal with Corona vine oh yeah
oh yeah oh sorry sorry how dare I
question that it's not funny anymore if
it ever was imagine having an actual
president who handles things like an
adult who in December and January takes
action instead of too little too late in
mid-march
a president who talks about the human
toll at the press briefings and tries to
connect with people and their struggles
and the fact that this is a very scary
situation instead we have a president
who disbanded the pandemic response team
did nothing until late February early
March turns his press press briefings
into promotions for exciting new
products that might appeal to
coronavirus customers as they've been
referred to while having corporate CEOs
do promos for themselves while claiming
Trump was a literal gift from God we are
in trouble and if you watch the
briefings not just of governor's here in
the United States but watch the
briefings of world leaders in other
countries Justin Trudeau in Canada
Emmanuel macron in France
uncle amiracle in Germany you very
quickly realize we don't have a leader
here we're depending on governor's the
ones that are competent to hopefully
save us because we've got no leadership
coming from the Oval Office and the gift
from God rant from the my pillow
sycophant
it's III was hoping I would wake up and
that that wouldn't really have happened
yesterday but it did and this is where
we are today
we'll continue discussing this on the
david pakman show instagram at david
pakman show while you're there follow me
as well at david pakman we'll take a
quick break and be back after this